what a bunch of little Ewok saan Kimo do
when the penguin from Batman Returns
isn't there to lead him around we're
about to find out
minion so minions is a spin-off of the
despicable Me movies starring all the
minions so there's a whole herd of
minions but it concentrates on three
minions in particular and it shows that
from the beginning of time minions have
always existed to serve the biggest
baddest badass around they kind of hit a
rut because there's no one evil to serve
so they go out looking for someone they
come across scarlet overkill and her
husband who's voiced by Jon Hamm who was
the funniest part of the movie I thought
I don't know why he was so over-the-top
he made me laugh scarlet overkill is
voiced by Sandra Bullock ultimately she
wants to crown jewels she wants the
queen of England's crown she wants to
rule everything so that's what the
minions are trying to do for her and
then shenanigans ensue throughout now we
have our minion spin-off a thing about
this movie that's kind of tough but kind
of worked was the fact that the minions
don't really talk they make two little
minion sounds but not but they don't
actually make cohesive sentences but you
still know what they mean kind of shows
talking's a waste of time it's all about
body language but at a point you're like
alright I could really go for some
sentences come on give me words give me
English speaking characters enter in
your look oh god I almost forgot what
that sounded like this is so refreshing
and since the minions don't actually
talk it relies on what it can which is
slapstick most of its comedic spectrum
really concentrates on slapstick the
kind of slapstick in this movies simple
humor and kids were dying they were
loving it in this auditorium I mean you
would just fall over on his face and
kids were just roar does have some
conflicting tone we're like oh that's a
lot of humor for kids that's where oh my
gosh the minions in the hot tub with the
two fire hydrants ultimately insinuating
a threesome good luck explaining that
mom and dad I'm not saying I didn't
laugh in the movie the movie definitely
did have humor right chuckle door I was
like oh that's clever but ultimately
this isn't a movie that's great for all
ages not like adults can take their kids
to it they're like oh it's great for all
of us thanks inside out now you take
your kids to this and you're like this
is your time now you are welcome it's a
classic tale that spin-offs and sequels
do a lot a side character or side
characters like the minions were great
into franchises like hey let's give them
their own movie but their best is a
garnish their best as supporting
characters when you make of the main
character it does a lose a bit of that
magic now their little side jokes that
were refreshing in the old movies are
just in your face now you're like okay
it's just a lot of that all the time now
it's not
minions is bad it just doesn't have that
magic that we're accustomed to at this
point that magic that links adults with
kids so you could watch the movie
together and all enjoy it ultimately I
feel like this is the simplest review
I've ever done but the movies pretty
cut-and-dry it has slapstick humor kids
love it adults will tolerate it adults
will enjoy parts in the movie but
ultimately they are kind of like be like
hey I want to watch that again it's
family night come on let's watch minions
again
I can't wait kids are gonna love it I
know that because they were roaring in
this auditorium that's what the movie
set out to do and that's what the movie
succeeded in doing so in the end I'm
gonna push this one I'm gonna say
minions is a good time no alcohol
required it is because my sense of irony
isn't kicking in right now I don't know
think little Timmy should drink today
guys so minions have you seen it what
did you think about it but ever you
thought comment below let me know wanna
be in San Diego Comic Con from now until
Sunday so there are other movies coming
out this weekend I'm gonna try to review
them on top of the comic-con videos I'm
undoubtedly going to do when I get back
gonna be a really packed schedule I want
to see the gallows but if I don't if it
passes me by like Hercules did last year
she's kind of the imperfect world we
live in but I will try and if you're
gonna be at comic-con you see me say hi
it's always great talking with you guys
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you wanna see more click
right here to see more
you